écoute moi vraiment dans ma vie j'ai
vraiment pas fait beaucoup d'autres
choses que les blagues
[Musique]
j'avais autour de 16 ans et moi j'avais
dit à personne de ma famille j'avais
bouquet mon truc que j'avais écrit dans
de mon côté pendant deux mois et
quelques légers est prévu d'y aller tout
seul le dire à personne et finalement je
sors de chez moi et je croise par hasard
mon frère et ses potes et me disent tu
vas où et là moi je suis je mens pas je
ne peux pas mentir et beau que je lui
dis bah voilà écoute je vais jouer là
j'ai bouclé un truc c'est ce soir un
mois déjà trop cool et m'ont dit ben
vas-y on t'emmène et je me souviens
d'être là avec mon coca quand j'entends
mon nom alors c'est à moi de monter sur
scène la panique et finalement ça
c'était super bien passé
je crois que le tout premier elie kakou
moi j'ai des souvenirs très jeune j'ai
genre vraiment 6 7 ans et je fais le
sketch d'elie kakou à mes parents quoi
baptiste lecaplain que je rencontre à
montréal quand j'ai justement 15 ans et
je vais le voir je dis voilà j'aimerais
faire de l'humour et lui super sympa il
prend un bout de papier il m'écrit trois
endroits aux jouets dont le chinchman
comedy club et je contacte le chinchman
comedy club suite à son papier et je
fais ma première scène grâce à baptiste
lecaplain qui m'a donné les adresses sur
un papier dont climat marqué de fou
c'était à montréal j'avais fait une
vidéo à montréal où je jouais un
parisien je marchais dans la rue et je
faisais le cliché type du parisien et la
vidéo elle avait bien marché à montréal
le lendemain je marchais avec mon pote
dans la rue et une meuf qui me vois tu
fais à regarder c'est l'humour
[Rires]
c'est catastrophique
catastrophique je me souviens j'étais à
montréal j'étais dans une phase
d'intense tu vois ces jeunes mais de
rien quand tu te lances dans ce genre de
métier tutu saute dans le vide je doit
animer un spectacle en plus ça veut dire
que je fais la présentation et je passe
entre chaque humoriste là j'arrive sur
scène et je m'y attendais pas ils sont
dans la salle et là je fige jute et
alizée et je fais le choc catastrophique
de ma vie est entre chaque humoriste
doit revenir se dire t'imagines je viens
je me mets lit il ya un humoriste qui
vient est là je dois revenir excepté une
catastrophe et je me suis dit mais mes
parents ils vont se dire mais il va
jamais arrivé dans ce milieu quoi
pendant un mois j'ai travaillé dans une
piscine c'est je faisais le test là de
lola donc autant dire que je foutais pas
grand chose j'ai vendu des merguez aussi
des sandwichs merguez à montréal
j'ai fait ça deux jours
la première folie c'est j'avais acheté
une sacoche du hors jeu pas trop dans le
luxe mais c'était marque mythique en
fait ce que j'ai mais celle que tu
artistique et finalement le premier jour
de tournage du film les méchants je me
fais voler la sacoche et je me suis dit
c'est quoi la vie à la raison en fait
qu'est ce que je fous avec ça en fait
j'ai juste besoin d'un trou dans lequel
il faut mettre nos carnets quoi
la première fois que seuls à montréal
donc j'avais une quinzaine d'années
parce que j'ai une tante qui vit là-bas
que j'adore donc je suis allé là bas en
vacances
un moment donné je suis tombé amoureux
de l'endroit je vois leur industrie de
l'humour je vois qu'ils font de l'humour
à l'américaine moi ce que j'ai mais tu
vois du stand up classique et je me suis
dit bon il faut que j'aille là-bas
primaire d'avoir 15 ans chez avec les
amis on va à l'épicerie j'ai toujours
fait plus vieux j'ai dû aller acheter de
la monza la pomme du smirnoff ice les
alcools d'adolescents quoi et j'ai dû me
mettre une cuite au parc avec mes amis
je pense c'est ça mais première cuite
tu en algérie avec redone vous guerrab à
la can qu'aujourd'hui m'envoie un
message et mme di maulo dit chercher un
humoriste pour son émission moi je suis
trop chaud je suis arrivé je me souviens
très bien ce terme hardier je dis bon si
je vais à l'émission j'aimerais faire ça
j'avais écrit la chronique je vous ai
faite devant lui il m'a dit bon bah on
se voit jeudi sans mauvais jeu de mot ça
a cliqué direct
je pense que la première fois que j'ai
dit je t'aime à quelqu'un j'ai menti
pour être très honnête avec toi mais je
n'ai pas dit beaucoup j'ai été élevé
d'une manière ou aimer ce patron un truc
qui se dit c'est un truc qui se fait
qu'ils se prouve par des actes
[Applaudissements]
je crois mon premier je suis avec un
gars il est bien plus vieux je suis à
chevy chevilly-larue là où j'ai grandi
on sandwich tous ensemble et tout moi
c'est mon premier bon délire et après le
mec était plus vu il a essayé de tous
nos racketter je me souviens je me
souviens grave bien pas réussi ils
avaient des tic le mec je me souviens
cram bien c'est parce que je pense qu'il
vient aujourd'hui s'il tombe là dessus
j'espère savoir mais mais tu as quand
même essayer de vous racketter je te
rappelle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]